(soft music)
- [Narrator] I've been
thinking a lot recently
about microcosms because
recently in my own life,
understanding what a microcosm is
has really helped me live
a better life day to day,
and I really hope that if
you are in a rough place,
you'll consider what I'm about to say,
and hopefully you can gain
some new ideas so that you can
trend your life in a better direction.
Okay, so a microcosm is
defined as a community, place,
or situation regarded as
encapsulating in miniature
the characteristic qualities or features
of something much larger.
Feel free to pause the video
and really soak that in,
and while you're soaking that
in, let me ask you a question.
What's the difference
between life and living?
You know, life itself may seem
like a simple enough concept
because we talk about it all the time.
I have a life, you have a life.
It's the thing we are all a
part of and all seem to have.
But if I ask you to
describe what your life is,
it's a little bit more difficult to do so
because there's so much involved in life
and your life is kind of just everything
that has to do with you.
Your family situation growing up,
your family situation right now,
it might be the job that you have,
the job that you want to have,
your hopes and dreams for the future,
your trauma and regret of the past,
every idea that bounces around your skull
or has bounced around in your skull.
Life is everything, and since
it describes everything,
it also kind of describes
nothing in particular.
It's an all encompassing
idea that is basically
just a theme and a concept,
something we're all familiar with
but none of us truly understand.
Living on the other hand is
something that we experience,
something that you are doing right now.
Living is something you've always done
and something you always
will do because by definition
before you were living
was before you were you,
and when you stop living,
you will stop being you,
so you and living are the same thing.
You don't know what it's like to not live.
In some ways though,
your life and your living
are not unlike each other.
They both deal with similar
people, places and things.
They both have familiar faces,
people you know and love
or strongly dislike and want to avoid.
Both have dealt and will
deal with similar emotions,
similar feelings, tendencies,
actions, and reactions,
but despite their commonalities,
one remains a stranger,
something we can only look
at through abstraction,
through memories we recall but can't see,
and places we'll go but never be,
because no matter how much
we think about our life,
it will never make sense to us completely.
It's impossible to see it all at once.
It's impossible to grasp what our life is.
We only see fragments
and patterns and themes
and in a lot of ways,
that's exactly what life is.
It's a pattern of
moments, strung together.
It's the overarching theme
of decisions that we've made
in days like today, so
if we take a step back
and we think about our entire life
and we don't like what we see,
we're basically saying we
don't like the pattern,
we don't like the theme.
If life is everything all at once
and living is the day to day,
then by definition, each
day is a microcosm of life.
Each day we live is a situation
that encapsulates in miniature
the characteristic qualities
or features of our life,
and when we start to realize
this, we'll start to realize
that life isn't really
something we can interact with.
We don't have access to our life.
The only thing that we
have access to is living,
playing it out day by
day, decision by decision,
and our tendencies and our
impulses to do certain things
are essentially the only
thing that we can influence
when it comes to our existence.
So what does this all mean?
Well, it means that if
you survey your life,
you look at the direction
that you're heading,
you look at the things that you dislike
about your life and about yourself.
Maybe you don't like the fact
that you never have the
motivation to go to the gym
or you can't seem to focus at work,
and it leads to poor job performance
which leads to less money,
which means that you can't
put food on the table.
Maybe you're not proud of who you are.
Maybe you don't take care of yourself.
Maybe you have serious feelings of regret
about things you did or
didn't do in the past.
Maybe you have wild
uncertainty about the future
or you're fairly convinced that
there is no future for you.
Well, these things are all life things,
but you don't experience life.
You experience living.
Living is confined by
constant beginnings and ends,
sunrise, sunset, again
and again and again.
You are living right now and
it's all you've been doing,
so if there are things that
you don't like about your life
then the only thing you
can do to change them
is to change the way you live today.
Maybe you're thinking
I need to quit smoking,
and one day I'm gonna quit
smoking for the rest of my life,
and I'm gonna live the rest of my life
free from this nasty habit,
and I'm gonna be happy and
healthy all the live long day
as if that's somehow different
than not smoking today,
'cause each time we wake up,
we're confronted with an opportunity
to echo the familiar motif
that's become the central theme,
or we can realize that our entire life
is crafted in moments like these,
so are we gonna continue
to water the same tree
or are we gonna plant a new seed?
And I swear, I'm not trying
to be Dr. Seuss here.
A lot of that shit rhymed,
but hopefully you get what I'm saying.
There is no difference
between going to the gym today
and going to the gym for
the rest of your life,
because going to the gym
for the rest of your life
is not something you can do.
It's never been something
you've had the ability to do.
Going to the gym for the rest of your life
is going to the gym today.
A big thank you to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
You guys know that I'm a big fan of AG 1
and have been taking
it every single morning
for about two years.
AG 1 supports your energy, focus,
gut health, immunity, and mental clarity,
all without the need to take
multiple products or pills,
and I really do feel
better when I'm taking it,
and I think that's because
there's basically no competing
with the amount of vitamins and nutrients
in one scoop of this stuff,
and the fact that it's sourced from
whole food ingredients and super foods
means that it's extremely bio available,
unlike so many multivitamins
that you can buy off store shelves.
AG 1 comes in a form that is super useful
to your body and your body
just soaks it up, goes yum,
thank you so much, I feel great now.
So if you guys are
interested in joining me
in this very simple
health optimization habit
then if you use my link
in the description below,
you also get a year's supply
of the vitamin D3 and K2 complex,
which I also use every single morning,
and you also get five AG 1 travel packs
with your first purchase.
So once again, use my link
in the description below
to take advantage of this offer,
and thank you so much to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
Guys, if you like this video
and you got something out of it,
it would be a huge help
if you actually hit
the literal like button
because that helps the video rank better,
and if you're on Instagram anyways,
consider following the
Better Ideas Instagram.
But if you're not on Instagram,
don't get Instagram to follow Better Ideas
because you're probably better off
not being on Instagram to be honest.
Other than that, thank
you so much for watching
and I'll catch you in the next video.
(soft music)